how you doing buddy what's good brother
how you feeling good man what do you got
tonight
you know it's funny you brought this up
man I um
I I honestly believe and I was just kind
of reflected on my own life and stuff
you know the early stages when I was
doing the craziness you know I mean you
know doing your thing getting your game
up and all that
and I was watching uh watching you
watching Andrew Tate when he was out you
know I mean of course free free uh
Andrew interesting but and then keeping
my eye on uh uh Myron and fresh the one
thing I noticed okay they all have women
in the background
adding value
and then I thought about you I'm like
well you know Rich mentions he has a
woman and she takes care a little the
cooking and all this other kind of stuff
I'm like
so I would ask you this this is I
believe this and I want to know what you
think
I believe that women want to find the
guy that they can add value to it man
that they can follow the man that they
can love honor and respect and we'll
have no problem doing these things you
know I mean like what do you think about
that
yeah that's interesting
um
women are fascinating aren't they yes
they are
so do women want to find a guy and
compliment his life
is that their life mission today
I don't think so Matt really but is it
part of the heart like is this something
that's ingrained in them when they find
the right dude
you know and not to put your information
out there but I would I would wager that
you don't have to ask or never have to
ask your woman any woman in your life
once you built yourself up to where you
want to be to do little things like you
know maybe dust up or take the dishes
out dishwasher or you know I mean uh hey
look man you know you want to keep it
real it's still it's still a job in a
long-term relationship to keep a woman
in line you still have to like look
women get lazy in a long-term
relationship if you let them you know
you know if they show up and they're
like uh you know they're taking care of
your laundry they make your bed you know
they're cooking you dinner when they're
done cooking the dinner they take care
of the dishes and they put them away you
know sort of things like that
women will get lazy over time and you'll
have to put your foot down and say look
you know what got you in the door
I need to see you keep doing those
things now that you're in the door you
don't get to get lazy or lighten up on
stuff like that
um I don't know many guys that can just
you know kick their feet up and
she's she's always going to compliment
his life exactly all the time you're
still going to have to remind them like
the thing with women is they have to
how can I put this I mean I'll just say
it they have to know that they're
replaceable and they have to have some
anxiety in a relationship around that
they can't be completely they can't be
in Comfort all the time there has to be
a little bit of discomfort
if you know what I'm saying so you know
these women that you're saying you know
you you're talking about uh Tate or
fresh or whatever
look I don't know about those guys
personal lives I mean I've I've talked
to Andrew
uh a lot uh publicly and privately you
know we were on WhatsApp and [__] it's a
shame that they're doing to them you
know what they're doing right now
um
but
you don't know what's going what went on
in his relationships with women
um I am very certain like you know one
of the things that he made clear is that
he's got women and he's got children
with women not a woman but women
I am fairly certain from the
conversations that I've had with many
men that have multiple women in their
lives or have children with multiple
women in their lives that it's not all
fun and games and rainbows and
butterflies there's there's infighting
there's jealousy like you have to put
them up in separate houses if you buy
one of Mercedes you gotta buy the other
one a Mercedes and it's got to be the
same trim because if that Mercedes is
white and hers is silver and it's a
lower trim she gets pissed off right so
there's always game that's involved with
women on a long-term basis I don't think
anybody's got it perfect no matter how
they want to purport that their life is
perfect and it's excellent all I'll tell
you straight up man I still I still have
to set boundaries and I still have to
deal with [__] from time to time
it's not all the time it's like
85 percent great
but when it's not great you're like
it takes the wind out of your sales you
know what I mean like you got to deal
with [__] from time to time
I didn't want to give the idea that is
it's Utopia is perfect it's done no yeah
um I just noticed therefore and I I just
use the men that I named here because
this space will
instantly understand who they are they
get the status part but even like coming
up in the streets the guys who we call
the plugs or whatever
they had a lot of women maybe you know
I'm thinking about it now I guess those
women were competing to get to the top
to the top ranking and they were like
you said they were doing all this stuff
to get in the door and then of course it
slacks off once they feel because you
know women love to feel they feel
they've made it oh I'm the number one
now so I can kick my feet up and I don't
have to do these things anymore I didn't
think that part through that's that's a
good point well
you know they they say see so I'm gonna
break the internet right now I mean like
I know that we don't have 20 000 people
watching but I'm going to say something
that I think is very profound
um you know they say that once a woman
sees you as her hypergamous best option
then that's it you know she'll always
behave she'll be on her best behavior
other guys are invisible blah blah blah
and all that sort of stuff and I think
there's some element of Truth to some of
that in there somewhere but I don't
think based on my experience and I've
I've dealt with thousands of guys
whether it's people calling in on shows
like this or it's a private consult
one-on-one or it's at a conference that
I'm talking to people privately I mean
I've I've talked to thousands of of guys
and guys even with the best game with
the best life
through with you know a chick that sees
them as their hypergamous best option
women will still have contempt from time
to time you can't make a woman happy
you could
stand up comments completely happy not
completely happy stand-up comments stand
up com com Comics have been saying this
for years you could be the richest guy
the tallest guy the best looking guy you
could have a diamond dick that's 10
inches long
fireworks could shoot at her ass you
know when you have like the best of
everything you could have the best cars
why is it the guys like Tom Brady get
divorced why is it that you know Will
Smith fabulous actors yeah end up with
disastrous women and they take all of
their [__] or they're running through
Court what happened to Johnny Depp in
the last couple years with Amber Heard
right Elon Musk has been through how
many divorces of the women right like
Russell Wilson's going through it with
with the three or four that he made it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't matter how
top shelf of his you know of a guy that
you are even if you are her hypergamous
best option she will still find
something to have contempt with right so
maybe other guys will be invisible for
the most part but I still think that
women are
in this stage in history I don't know if
it was different 100 or 200 years ago
with the uh you know with the absence of
social media and the absence of you know
everybody putting up on the pedestals so
easily and unlimited validation and
attention they don't need no man and
they can work and they can have their
own house and all sort of stuff I don't
know if that would have changed much but
in this point in time in in history I
don't think that you can make a woman
happy
bro I mean so okay just as perfect as
you are you will never make a woman
happy you will never and I don't have
any pushback for that again I just I was
just having that thought on my huh
because I've seen women do these things
but you're right there's a there's gonna
come a point where you're gonna have to
put your foot down as the man that's
like being masculine you're gonna have
to like you said hey you got to keep
doing this or you're gone which really
keeps the women afraid like oh I don't
want to get I could see that as well
um so I say this to all people that I
talk to all the time and real quick
thank you so much for telling me about
the manual swamp bro you never lied now
I'm a few more months into it Jesus bro
these trenches ain't no joke I asked for
it this is what I get I'm stuck in the
mental swamp but
I never tell people is easy
relationships are hard
um
business relationships are hard but you
know when you you're living with this
woman if she's not bringing you peace
and you're not willing to let her go
like if you like you said we've all been
there I know I've been crushed I thought
I've fallen for the wrong woman and I'm
still paying for it it is what it is and
I knew better so I tell people that too
but but I have seen women work for it
and real quick the answer to your
question earlier man I think it was the
mid-80s it was the mid 80s in the U.S
when a government assistant came out you
know unless we got the welfare and all
that kicking the man out of the house
child support all that I think the
mid-80s is when we got that was the
beginning of the the today's woman here
in America at least I don't know about
the rest of the world isn't isn't all of
that in the mid 80s though a product of
what came from the 1920 19th Amendment
changed though
I think you can argue that I mean you
can you can kind of joke you can draw
the lines to it I want swimming I'm not
right to vote yeah I think you could
argue it I'm not saying that women
should or shouldn't have the right to
vote what I'm saying is you should you
should be able to vote if you have skin
in the game if you pay in the tax system
if you if you have land if you pay
probably you can get drafted you can get
drafted you should be able to vote you
know if you can pay taxes if you're if
you're a net positive contributor that's
what I'm saying right so if a chick can
do that good do it
you know
I'm not trying to exclude anybody from
this what I'm saying is though if you're
going to decide what happens with my
money that I pay taxes you best be
paying taxes too hey look as an
African-American man um I'm looking at
what San Francisco's proposing I don't
know if you saw anything on this with
their reparations uh they want to give
every African-American who can prove
they were descended of slaves in San
Francisco California my job there's no
slavery out there right doing back in
the day they wasn't part of that any any
African-American who can today who could
prove that they're descended slave
they're proposing five million dollars
uh and I think it's 95 000 a year
and I think that's for I want to say
50 years maybe 100 years or something
like that I didn't please don't quote me
on that y'all but the 5 million dollar
part yeah I'm like I need to move back
to California if y'all talking about
doing that because I can definitely
prove I'm the sin is a sledge does it
work
s whatever
but it's like hey if y'all gonna if
y'all gonna throw the money out there I
look at that as the same thing as I look
at this Bank bill out bro are you just
gonna throw you know if you're gonna
give almost 800 billion dollars to First
Republic Bank you know you can go ahead
yeah
when you when you look at the the way
the system work and the tax system work
and you know the financial policies the
monetary part like the thing that that
grinds my gears you know I've been
saying this for a few months now is why
do we pay taxes if they could just print
unlimited money right the difference the
difference between us here today
and let's use those slaves that are
talking about you know from ancestors
from San Francisco the difference
between us and those guys is they look
down at their ankles every day and they
saw the shackles they knew that they
were slaves most people today don't know
that they're Shackled at their slaves
you've got some maneuverability you've
got a little bit more maneuverability
but you're still a slave and you know
that's the funny part too because there
were no slaves in the 1800s in
California that's where the slaves went
to give Freedom like they came into
Canada if you can make it to California
we're good too so to me it just blows my
mind like how was San Francisco
offering reparations to people that they
didn't even enslave I mean you think you
would do better by offering that to uh
people of Chinese the sense because they
were the ones you know what happens this
is what happens when you give people
a vote that don't put that don't pay in
the tax system that don't contribute to
the that are net takers and these are
the policies that just make up you're
right man and again this is hey y'all
this is coming from a guy who my
grandmother's grandmother
died a slave all right I can prove it so
but unfortunately I don't live in San
Francisco because I you know they gonna
give out five million dollars I ain't
gonna lie to you I'm gonna get in that
line but I think it's absolutely wrong
I'll take out I want to see how that
[__] unfolds man it's gonna die it's not
gonna go anywhere bro that's not gonna
what about the slaves from like you know
the Roman Empire that were forced to
fight lions in the Coliseum like when's
the reparation coming from those times
how far do we go with this craziness
[__] man it's just it's it's never
ending it's never Andy and it's a you
know what
I'll say this and get out of here
because I know you got more people
waiting but the thing is this
in America at least I don't know what's
going on in Canada and the rest of the
world but Americans
don't know how to critically think
anymore
it's like you said people don't know how
to critically think people people don't
know it's it's it's not supposed to wear
away it's people it's worldwide people
are sheep people are humans people are
sheep humans are sheep so if you would
make this it's one of the reasons why
we're so successful as a species too by
the way because of Gossip because if
somebody says something everybody
follows it and it just sort of Builds on
it I mean silicon Silicon Valley Bank
those people did some really stupid
stuff right but the run on that bank was
so incredible because that rumor got out
so fast and and you know technology is
where it is today but Americans well
people people don't think anymore
everyone wants something and it just
doesn't make any sense you can't do that
you can't okay we're gonna give all
African-Americans who are descended to
Slaves money all right and then if you
start trying to prove it like all you
have to do is show us via DNA that you
know you're descending some slaves well
Thomas Jefferson had a lot of slaves he
made a lot of babies with them so you
got all these white folks who could have
come out and be like look I'm descending
from slave give me my money it could be
some Rockefellers out there some
Kennedy's out there look we're
descending from slaves give us some
money it's just a law that's passed like
is this legislation that's gone through
it's this is something on the books
about money or trying to push you
through it's a proposal in San Francisco
that they're they were really trying
hard to push it through and I don't
think it's going to go anywhere it would
be foolish again California you know
what I mean but you know the second you
can't miss it it's on there it's uh you
know the last thing man you got any hats
what's up what's your merch bro I got
your I got the book I mean I would love
to grab a hat or something
I got no I don't have hats I just have
uh mugs and t-shirts and a bunch of
other stuff I don't even wear some
T-shirts anymore because I'm going all
styling and profiling now man I got that
I see that bro Taylor's shirts so I see
that man that looks I ain't gonna lie to
you bro that looks nice dude I remember
when you first put one on I was like ah
the collar looks a little flimsy but
that that one right there that looks
that's proper right there this is an
Italian cut right you know you got to
get them done right gotta get them done
right hey thanks for having me on bro I
really appreciate it what you doing bro
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out